Black Panther blew past box-office
estimates in its opening weekend huge
crowds of people packed into theaters
across the country to see this new
superhero movie so far the film has
raked in an estimated one hundred and
ninety-two million dollars in the US and
Canada that makes it the fifth
highest-grossing opening weekend in
Hollywood history
Jericka Duncan shows us how Black
Panther is making its mark as a cultural
phenomenon the big cat is out of his
cage and pouncing on the big screen
Black Panther is the latest in a long
line of Marvel comic book superheroes
turned movie stars and this one has fans
and a feline friend's mom fantastic
fantastic easily the best Marvel movie I
was just so looking for this movie since
the day that trailer came out typically
movies superheroes whether men of steel
gods of thunder or Dark Knights are
white so Black Panther has appealed to
comic book fans as well as a more
general black audience and when those
audiences intersect
they're super excitement the film holds
special meaning for many longtime fans
and particularly for Arielle Johnson I
feel like I might actually this movie
comatose I don't I might need to be
carried out Johnson a self-described
blurred
that's a black nerd that is the beauty
of a comic book story it's one of the
first black women to open a comic book
store on the East Coast
she opened amalgam comics and coffee
house in Philadelphia a little more than
two years ago she's been waiting for a
film like black panther since she fell
in love with comic books as a girl when
did your love for superheroes again I
always liked superheroes but it wasn't
until I was about 11 or so that I was
actually introduced to the x-men and the
thing that really grabbed me was was
storm
because up until that point I had never
seen a black woman superhero there's
something clicks when you start to see
yourself you know reflected back at you
this isn't the first time a black
comic-book hero was the lead role in a
film the three-part blade series
beginning in the late 90s start Wesley
Snipes as a vampire hunter but when you
think about the people who were around
blade in that movie it wasn't like an
all-black cast I think the thing about
Black Panther it is essentially a black
movie you know in the in you know and
and and those turn like in Hollywood
terms but usually when when the movie is
a black movie white audiences don't see
it but that's not the case with Black
Panther the box office tells the tale of
the film success this weekend it brought
in nearly two hundred million dollars
and it set the record for a live-action
superhero movie on Rotten Tomatoes with
a score of 97% I knew for a fact that it
was going to be a huge success John
Jennings is a professor of media and
cultural studies at the University of
California Riverside and he's the
co-author of black comics Returns the
Black Panther film as a cultural
phenomenon because images like this have
not really been seen in major
multiplexes before images like black
director Ryan Coogler leading a
predominantly black cast and black
royalty set in a scientifically advanced
African nation the fictional what condo
a lot of these films that we've seen
before like you know 12 years of slave
or precious or something like that are
dealing with heavy subjects that are
positing black suffering as a central
mode of existence for black Americans I
think that black panther is a
celebration of what's at the end of that
trauma right this is about black joy so
what do you think is different about
this film well because I think people
are just excited about it and because
it's a Marvel property because it's a
well-known character it's people are
gonna be able season for CBS this
morning
Jericka Duncan Philadelphia that's why
it's so exciting I thought Ariel Johnson
made such a good point
normally when it's a black cast and a
black crew it's designed for black
audiences or so they think this has
shown that this is simply a it's a black
movie no question but it's a great movie
that's how important yeah reporting from
the backseat of my son's car with his
friends it was a huge debate about
vibranium which means they loved the
movie and what's inside of it as much as
his sister loved the message and I'm
assuming your son is white that makes a
point well why don't see this movie it's
the first weekend ya know that's a fun
exciting noir outing